a character's death mirroring life the
change in Direction the script had to
take to reflect the tragic passing keep
watching to find out everything we know
about t'challa's death in wakanda
Forever Chadwick boseman's death at only
43 years old was a devastating loss to
the world and the loss rippled through
so many different spheres in a piece she
penned for enscape in 2020 WNBA Star
Chinese agumika said that the actor's
role in Black Panther had a lasting
cultural Legacy for black people the
athlete said in many ways black panther
helped normalize African Heritage and
style in popular culture by truly
celebrating it agumika talked about
using the wakanda forever salute before
games in 2018 something which according
to an article in vidette online is
common in sports and some sports stars
like LeBron James and Lewis Hamilton
used the salute in tribute to Bozeman
following his death in an interview with
inverse writer and director Ryan coogler
talked about the original draft he had
written for the sequel to Black Panther
and how it would have focused on
grappling with the Fallout of the blip
in Avengers end game coogler explained
the character was going to be grieving
the loss of time you know coming back
after being gone for five years he was
grieving time he couldn't get back grief
was a big part of it while the script
was Rewritten to Pivot around the
real-life death of Bozeman some things
remain the same from the first draft
such as neymore being the antagonist
Bozeman's real-life death also inspired
the manner of death of the character
t'challa in the beginning of black
panther wakanda forever fancy shuri and
Race Against Time to find a cure for her
brother's illness which is never
disclosed we know from the film that he
hid it from shuri mirroring Bozeman's
own private fight with cancer in real
life in the opening scene Charis trying
to recreate the heart-shaped herb plant
which gives the Black Panther his powers
following killmonger's destruction of
all the remaining heart-shaped herbs in
the first Black Panther movie In wakanda
Forever it's implied that had Shiri
managed to recreate the heart-shaped
herb properly in the lab in would have
saved t'challa in the mid-credit scene
of the film Nakia introduces shuri to
t'challa's son whom the Black Panther
had time to prepare for his coming death
it's revealed that t'challa did not want
Nakia or his son to come to the funeral
prompting the two to have their own
private ceremony in Haiti to honor the
Fallen Hero thus we know that t'challa
had time to make some preparations for a
death that he saw coming even as he
seemed to hide some of those
preparations from shuri t'challa's Death
was kept so close to Bozeman's real life
cause of death that fans found
themselves mourning the death of the
actor all over again a number of fans on
social media commented on the way that
t'challa's death was handled in the film
in the Marvel Studios subreddit one
Reddit user said I'm still in shock that
t'challa died of an illness that he kept
secret another user praised the film for
the approach it took toward the death
the user explained I'm glad they did
that I think anything else would have
felt uncomfortable either a character
who died weak or a couch who died in a
more badass way than the actor who
portrayed him he died in a sad realistic
and understandable way that lets the
audience mourn both Chadwick and
t'challa it's notable that there is a
precedent in the comics for sure taking
over the role of the Black Panther not
due to t'chella's death but due to
severe injury in Black Panther Volume 5
number 2 t'challa nearly dies after a
battle with someone he thinks is Doctor
Doom but is only a robot only to then
fall in a battle with the real Doctor
Doom the battle comes after Namor offers
t'challa a chance to join a cabal
composed of himself Norman Osborne Loki
Emma Frost the hood and Dr Doom with
t'challa near death shuri takes up the
mantle of black panther obviously the
movie stayed far away from this plot as
most of those characters have yet to be
introduced in the MCU but this
alternative route allowed t'challa's
death to closely mirror Chadwick
boseman's real-life death creating a
chance for the audience to mourn the
late actor
foreign